one issue for example where i depart
pretty strongly from the traditional
republican line
is i think a lot of folks in the
republican party they see what's going
on with google
apple facebook with big tech writ large
and they say well
we don't like what they're doing we
don't like the fact that they censor
conservatives but they're private
companies and so we can't actually do
anything with them
and my response to that is well first of
all they're not actually private
companies they benefit from a ton of
special government privileges
but also they're just too powerful like
however they got there
they're way too powerful and they're way
too big at this point so i'm willing to
go
you know with with ken buck and with
josh hawley and with others and say look
we've got to actually reign in the power
of these companies because if they
control what you're allowed to say in
america
we don't have a first amendment anymore
if we don't have the first amendment we
don't have a real country
i'm dave rubin and joining me today is
the author of hillbilly elegy a memoir
of a family and culture in crisis
founder of the venture capital firm
naria and
current senate candidate from the great
state of ohio
jd vance welcome to the reuben report
thanks for having me dave good to see
you
good to be with you you know i've wanted
to chat with you for a while because i i
find that on twitter i find some people
who make some sense
who actually are saying some things that
actually
seem like a sensible way forward for
this country for this earth the whole
thing you
you're on that short list uh for people
that don't know who we are
can you give a little bit of the
backstory that's sort of what the book
is about and then the movie but can you
just give me a little
brief bio just to kick us off yeah sure
so
i was raised by my my working-class
grandparents in middletown ohio which is
in southwestern ohio it's a steel town
and the basic story is because of a host
of complicated reasons but one of which
is that my mother struggled with opioid
addiction
you know my grandparents had to take
care of me and we grew up in pretty
rough and tumble environment didn't have
a lot of money didn't have a lot of
support
but things sort of worked out for me as
i like to say america worked for me
and i think it really did for for a
number of reasons but
two two reasons at the top of the list
or my grandma was always very love
loving and supportive she was as you
know dave because you read the book but
she was not a traditional grandmother in
a lot of ways she loved to say the f
word she had 19 handguns when she died
but she was also a woman of incredibly
deep faith
and then i also was well served by the
us marine corps and i listed in
april of 2003 which is right as the iraq
war was ramping up
marine corps is this incredible
experience for me gave me a lot of a
a lot of important lessons a lot of
lifelong friendships um
and then you know from there went to
college
went to law school uh sort of started
working in silicon valley in the
technology industry
uh got connected with uh with peter
thiel out there and then while i was
working with peter actually published
this book hillbilly elegy
which happened to coincide how could i
possibly known with this remarkable
political environment that we lived in
2016
where you know donald trump on the right
was coming out of nowhere and taking
over the republican party
you know bernie sanders was coming out
of the left and almost taking over the
democrat party
and so i sort of found myself all of a
sudden a national commentator and i'm
glad that you like my twitter
uh you know a lot of a lot of your
colleagues in the media don't but uh
that
i'm not sure they're my colleagues but
they they are in
the media whatever that is but but you
bring up an interesting point there
because you yeah that sort of put you on
the map around 2016 the trump thing is
happening
and in many ways your story and the book
and then the movie sort of
is the story of the people that kind of
supported trump right
yeah it is so you think of the story of
my family so my grandfather was like a
working class blue dog democrat he was a
classic
steel union democrat socially moderate
very patriotic loved his country but
sort of always saw democrats as the
party of the working man and the working
women
by the time you know trump came around
in 2016
most of those non-college-educated you
know classic white working-class
white voters that was sort of the the
buzzword in 2016.
they had shifted so hard to trump and so
i think a lot of the reason that the
book did very well
is people were picking it up trying to
understand like who are all of these
voters
who even you know some some a lot of
white work class voters actually
supported barack obama in 2008 or 2012
but had this really hard shift right in
support of donald trump
and so i think a lot of folks were
trying to understand what was going on
and the book
obviously benefited from that were you
surprised that there was a jump
from those values being in the middle of
the country
steel workers industries changing all
that and then to an actual
political movement from a guy who was a
real estate developer in new york
you know it's it's interesting i i
definitely found
the reaction to the book as sort of this
political insight into a lot of voters a
little bit weird because
you know the book doesn't mention
clinton it doesn't mention trump it's
not really a political book
uh in in the classic sense uh but i
understand why people are trying to
understand like why do these folks in
the middle of the country
feel left behind so condescended to and
of course
they feel left behind they feel
condescended to because in many cases
they actually are
they have been left behind they have
been uh looked down upon
by a lot of folks in power so i
appreciate that
people were at least for a brief period
trying to understand that demographic of
the country
uh so so obviously the book benefited
from that and and i think hopefully it
did provide some insights from that that
group of people or to that group of
people
yeah you mentioned the blue dog democrat
i'm not sure how much you know about my
story but i i was a lefty i was a
progressive the whole thing but i would
say if the blue dog democrats still
existed but they're basically like the
unicorn at this point
there would be maybe some room for me to
say i could kind of be on that side
probably not at this point but do you
think that person exists anymore and if
they do exist
are they basically just a modern
conservative i mean is that is that sort
of what you
are at this point yeah i i think that
the people like that certainly exist i
think donald trump fits into that where
to your point even though he was a real
estate developer i think he's he's
at his cart right he's a guy from queens
who works with a lot of working-class
people construction workers sales people
and so forth
and so he's always identified with those
folks at a deep emotional level and
they've identified with him
you know donald trump is up there i
certainly think my you know my
my attitude towards politics is like a
working class or a blue collar
conservatism
uh there are other people out there i
think jim banks is a really interesting
guy
representative from indiana i think
tucker carlson talk about another guy
who's sort of
you know an east coast uh wasp in the
classic sense but i think
identifies with blue collar folks in a
very deep way it obviously focuses a lot
on them in a show
so i think there are actually a lot of
us out there who think
the the purpose of the republican party
should be to better serve its voters
um but but i think they're all on the
right at this point i mean there there
were maybe a couple of blue dog
democrats even five ten years ago
they all got primary they all got
effectively kicked out of the party
and they're just clearly not welcome
there anymore so if they exist at all
they're they're sort of on our side of
the aisle
yeah i mean that's what i've been saying
i know a few of these people
and i think it's kind of a worthy fight
if you want to still say you're a
democrat and try to you know do
something as the house is burning down
but it just doesn't seem like it could
work to me are you uh
are you surprised how radical the left
has gone that there is no room for these
people i mean i guess
as someone running for senate now you're
kind of excited it's like yeah come over
here we're all right
um i'm definitely surprised and a little
startled by how crazy the left has gone
over the last 10 years i mean
in part this is a consequence of
demographics right the left is basically
the party
of upper middle class and upper-class
elites
and then some working-class minorities
who are sort of still along for the ride
on the democratic party
but really those folks don't have a ton
of influence in the party right
so it's partially just sort of who is
leading the left i think it's it's like
you know professionally educated people
who went to ivy league schools
who tend to have pretty radical views
about politics because of it
i think a little of it is definitely
economic i think the the left
is not comfortable with the fact that a
lot of people are dissatisfied with the
way
the economy has worked the way the
manufacturing economy has worked
and instead of saying you know maybe
this is a serious problem that we've
like
lost our entire manufacturing industrial
base to china i think their response is
to complain
that the people who care about our
industrial base in the first place
they're obviously racist or xenophobic
or idiots
so i think part of what's going on is
it's just like the composition of the
left has really radically changed
but then part of what's going on is the
left completely unable to solve
america's real problems is sort of
resorted
to criticizing most americans as
backwards or racist in some way
and so yeah it's really startling it's
really depressing
but you know it is it is where we is and
unfortunately you know
it is what it is and i think
unfortunately we just have to fight
these people
where do you think trump now fits into
this thing because you you were not on
board the trump train in 2016 right you
did vote for him in in 2020
um where do you think he sort of is now
like the worth of trump at this point
uh yeah you're right i was i was a late
adopter to trump um and i remember peter
thiel giving me crap for it back in 2016
and of course eventually said you know
you're right you were right i the guy
was uh
was was was saying a lot of smart things
uh did support him in 2020 i mean
i think at a fundamental level trump is
still the leader of the republican party
right
um so to the extent that you have this
blue-collar patriotic movement within
the country
it's on the right most of those voters
are still very loyal to donald trump
and so i think he continues to have a
very important voice
either as a king maker in the party
certainly i think if he ran in 2024
there's a very good chance
he'd get elected president again so i i
tend to think that trump
has is is not going to disappear as a
force from american public life
and i think you know unfortunately
most republicans or at least most
republican leaders i think most
republican voters are very good about
this
most republican leaders i think don't
fully appreciate what trump represented
and so there isn't an obvious like
answer to trump if he just disappeared
tomorrow i do fear a little bit
that if trump just went the way of the
dodo you know decided well i'm gonna
focus on making money or i'm gonna go
play golf all day and not really worry
about politics anymore
like i don't know that there's an
obvious person to replace him right
there are some really good people like
desantis like josh molly um
but but but but outside of a few really
bright politicians
i think most people don't want to fully
embrace what trump represented for the
republican party which is which is a
tragedy
because i think it's it's ultimately you
know quibble with some things on the
on the margins but i think it's the
right direction for the party to go
right so you're saying guys like
desantis and holly are better than uh
romney and liz cheney is that that's the
few is that the controversial statement
you're making
yeah the the radical claim that i would
make is that josh hawley is much better
than liz cheney
and ron desantis is better than mitt
romney um but but but again
unfortunately i
actually think though the most elected
republicans
are not as far out there as liz cheney
um
they really don't like what trump
represents they sort of want the party
to be what it was during the bush era
2000 2004 and because of that there's
still a lot of resistance i mean even
one of the big takeaways from the trump
administration
is that when the entire party is
institutionally set against
the will of the president himself there
can be a lot of real bureaucratic fights
and i think so much of what
happened during the trump administration
is you know the trump trump folks wanted
to do something on trade
they were somewhat successful they were
also fought by members of their own
party
and so you don't just need one
politician you sort of need the entire
institution to reform itself
right so so where do you fit into that
like in terms of your beliefs at this
point
um are they are they all traditionally
conservative i mean i get what you're
saying you could maybe be
thought of as as one of those you know
15 year ago
uh blue dog democrat types but like what
would say
your broad sort of idea set look like
yeah i mean there are some traditionally
conservative ideas that i'm very
comfortable with so i'm very pro-life
i've always been pro-life i've always
cared a lot about that issue because i
think
you know when abortion becomes
widespread in society what effectively
does is send a message to families
that their babies are inconveniences
instead of you know real like blessings
for us to support
so so on some issues i'm very
traditionally conservative you know but
like one issue for example where i
depart pretty strongly from the
traditional republican line
is i think a lot of folks in the
republican party they see what's going
on with google
apple facebook with big tech writ large
and they say well
we don't like what they're doing we
don't like the fact that they censor
conservatives but they're private
companies and so we can't actually do
anything with them
and my response to that is well first of
all they're not actually private
companies they benefit from a ton of
special government privileges
but also they're just too powerful like
however they got there
they're way too powerful and they're way
too big at this point so i'm willing to
go
you know with with ken buck and with
josh hawley and with others and say look
we've got to actually reign in the power
of these companies because if they
control what you're allowed to say in
america
we don't have a first amendment anymore
if we don't have the first amendment we
don't have a real country
yeah it's interesting because i've
discussed this with tucker on his show
many
times and years like two or three years
ago i was still like no regulation don't
touch anything the libertarian side of
me
and i actually have come more towards
what you just laid out there which is
what
josh hawley's been laying out but what
do you think that actually looks like
because if the founders could have never
imagined
something more powerful than the
government which is what we've got i
mean do you want to send government
bureaucrats to look at the google
algorithm as if they could do it or
or is it breaking these companies up i
mean i know you like the competition
side and we'll talk about rumble in just
a little bit
but like what does it actually look like
that you would want done to bigtech
yeah yeah so so yeah you're bracketing
the things you can still do in the
private sector which i think is
important i think that there are there
are ranges of options from less radical
to more radical right
so i think a slightly less radical
option is you just make
in the same way that like you can't
censor somebody because they're black or
because they're white
you well you know you used to not be
able to do that over the last couple of
years
yeah yeah yeah give it a couple more
months
you can't for example turn off an
electric utility can't turn off
somebody's
power because they don't you know like
the sex or the gender or the race of the
people who
need the power i think one thing you
could do is just add political
viewpoint to that protected class say if
you're conservative and you're censored
on facebook
you basically have a right to file a
lawsuit in the same way that if you're
censored because you're black you have a
right to file a wall so that's that's
sort of
you know option one i think a little bit
more radical is the anti-trust option
effectively breaking up these companies
uh making it impossible
uh for them to sort of control the
discourse because you have more
competition among the platforms that are
out there
you know i i i'm basically supportive of
that though i think that you have to do
it the right way or effectively these
sort of companies just reform as natural
monopolies
uh the the thing that i'm really
intrigued by is like
does the business model of silicon
valley actually make sense right so you
know i have my iphone right here
if you think about like what an iphone
is it really is a thing that gets you to
stare at it as much as possible
so that it can take your data and then
sell it back to you in the form of
targeted advertising there's a pretty
good argument that the silicon valley
business model
which distracts a lot of attention and
effectively is built upon the theft of
data
should be completely outlawed right and
make it illegal to sort of
you know collect people's data without a
whole host of additional protections
i think that would blow up the model of
silicon valley i think maybe that's
that's that's
that's too radical uh but if i'm
actually landing my car
hey as a as a guy that just started a
tech company that's doing subscription
and doesn't sell data
keep keep it going keep it going but but
i have to say that
that honestly i i would be supportive of
that if you basically said you can no
longer effectively steal people's data
i think that would be really good for
our country and i actually think it
would be good for the tech sector
because
like the tech sector whether it's in
digital technology or
pharmaceuticals or you know energy and
transportation
like it's become a little bit like these
devices i think have become a little
parasitic
on capital on high quality talent and
there's this weird way where our entire
economy like
silicon valley has worked pretty well if
you look at the s p 500 silicon valley
has great returns in their companies
but like the entire rest of the country
and the entire rest of the economy has
been relatively stagnant
that's a big problem that's not just a
censorship problem that's a broader
economic problem
but i think we have to be worried about
that problem too so i'm pretty radical
on this in other words
go after their special privileges break
them up maybe even
illegalize the entire business model
because i care about
having a real economy in a real country
again at some level though
do you think it's just kind of too late
like we had
trump for four years we had all the
hearings we all saw zuckerberg and jack
from twitter and the rest of them
trot out there and basically make up a
lot of nonsense half the time under oath
right and we did and we didn't do
anything then so why would the biden
administration that obviously is
is no fan of some of the ideas you're
putting out there why would they be the
ones to do this
well i don't think they're going to be
the ones to do this i mean i definitely
think it's going to be a combination of
leverage from republican senators and
hopefully i'm one
in the not too distant future it's also
going to require a new republican
administration i think again
all this stuff is going to happen on the
right because the left is way too in the
pocket of the big tech industry
um all that said you know i try to take
a very long view on this you may know
this guy nigel farage he's sort of the
legion
yeah of the uk i've gotten drunk with
him
okay well he's yeah he's a good guy to a
good guy to have a beer with
um you know one of the things that i've
taken just from getting to know nigel a
little bit is like the brexit
thing took 25 years of institution
building of convincing voters
of convincing media a ton of
institutional biases against the brexit
movement
electorally there were some weird issues
of course the media
hated nigel farage and thought he was a
terrible person so i i tend to think
about this in a longer term way that
like the goal here
isn't to fix this tomorrow yes you know
i'm i
i wish that more could have happened
over the last four years and actually
addressing the tech
problem but i think if we take that
attitude it can become self-defeating
and what we have to do in this moment
is actually gear ourselves up for a
fight in a long-term fight
and if we do that i actually think the
people are with us i think that we're on
the right side of this issue
and we'll eventually win it just may
take some work and a lot of time
yeah do you think we just need a sort of
separation from
all of the institutions that the left
has built that we're now watching
crumble i mean do we need to just build
new institutions new technological uh
answers and solutions just just really
like a complete
parallel economy uh yeah i mean i think
we probably do
um we need to build parallel businesses
of course because the businesses have
gone
fully in the tank for the left like the
biggest multinational corporations are
now effectively
um enterprises of the left i also think
we have to build alternative educational
institutions
you know one of the things the left has
been incredibly effective at
is monopolizing education in this
country right they've basically created
a system
whereby if you don't get a four-year
college degree it's very hard to even
apply for most middle class jobs right
even if they don't really require a
college degree they'll put it right on
the application like you know four-year
degree or
required and so what this has done is is
forced
a lot of people who just want to have a
middle class life
into the university system they've
acquired a lot of debt they've of course
acquired a lot of indoctrination along
the way
like the left is in some ways like in
this evil machiavellian sense sort of
genius
because they've made the most
left-leaning institutions the gatekeeper
of a good life in this society
conservatives have got to find an
alternative to this because we keep on
forcing all of our kids to go to
four-year colleges we shouldn't be
surprised that we keep on losing the
culture war
yeah i always describe it as the doctor
in the original alien movie
you know he kind of admires the pure
evil
the complete you know remorseless evil
of the alien he knows it's evil but he's
kind of like hey
you got to give the devil is due but so
so all that being said
um you also have a vc firm and and
you're actually
getting in the fight right now by uh by
getting involved with rumble can you
talk about that a little bit
yeah that's right yeah so so we launched
our vc firm in cincinnati
you know i'd been in vc the industry for
a few years i always wanted to do
something in my hometown
um so we launched it as a
cincinnati-based firm in 2019
you know myself a partner and a couple
of our employees who are who are great
and you know we we like on the one hand
we're just a classic vc firm right we
try to invest in really good companies
and help them grow
you know one of the companies i'm most
proud of that we invested in is a
company called
app harvest which is an agriculture
technology company in eastern kentucky
uh now has a close to two billion dollar
market cap and when we invested it was
it was really just in its formative
stages
um so a lot of good stuff happening but
yeah one of the companies i'm most proud
that we got involved with was rumble
and uh you know i know you know a lot
about rumble but the thinking there was
actually you know we were sort of
looking at a lot of the alternative tech
platforms in the wake of january the 6th
right it's like okay this is pretty
scary the president of the united states
just got booted off of social media
maybe these companies are too powerful
you know let's look at gab let's look at
parlor let's look at a lot of the
companies that are out there
that are actually providing something
like free speech to people who want to
live in the digital world
and uh you know liked a lot of the
companies that we looked at couldn't
quite get comfortable that they were
actually robust enough technology to
withstand
you know what eventually the platforming
incident that came against parlor that
effectively shut the site down for a
couple of months
but just kept on looking and we finally
met chris who's the the the ceo and the
founder of rumble who i know you know
well
yeah um and and and started like talking
to chris
and thinking okay so so you know first
of all their user metric numbers are
incredible they're growing
at a really remarkable clip they've
never had an infusion of capital so
they've sort of done all of this growth
organically
but also chris had built the platform
you know not to be like
a conservative website or a liberal
website but just to be a
true alternative website like the
technology was robust
you know we felt like well if aws tries
to de-platform this company they're not
going to be able to be successful
because of the way that chris had built
the underlying technology and so just
eventually got really excited about what
they were doing
uh made a big investment there you know
brought peter thiel along into the deal
he also made a big investment in the
company
and now it's just it's growing at a
really amazing clip and we think that
this could be
a true independent a political
alternative to big tech
right so i don't want to say too much at
the moment but i am having dinner
in miami with chris on friday so i'll
leave that part there but in essence
is is the goal that you guys sort of
want to replace aws that you guys would
basically
say hey we've got all of the
infrastructure chris is an engineer he's
been building this thing for 10 years
like we've got the infrastructure so
that you won't just be blown up like
parlor
because you're right that was the moment
where it was like everyone realized this
thing just
the the the severity of the situation
just went through the roof
that's right yeah more even than trump
being the platform parlor being
effectively kicked off the internet was
really radicalizing
you know to me and to a lot of other
people as well you know
certainly one of the options i'll put it
this way one of the options i think for
rumble is to become
a long-term apolitical true free speech
aws right the the sort of online web
platform that's not going to de-platform
you because you say things that the mob
doesn't like
but one of the things i've learned
working in the technology sector is you
always try to have a good plan and you
execute against it
but there are a lot of forks in the road
and i think rumble
you know has 10 different pathways to
the moon like this is not a company that
just has
one real option to go after and what i
think actually what what you know
there's always challenges with companies
and one of the challenges with rumble
that i think about
is they have such a big market
opportunity they have so much they could
do
that i think focusing and picking the
right strategic pathway
is almost going to be the biggest
challenge because the company again
they're just doing really well and
they've got a lot of real upside
right and not to do too much of a
commercial here but you guys had
you guys had the trump rally a couple
days ago live streamed on rumble over
500 000 people
i think biden's speech yesterday or the
day before 18 000 people on youtube
so so something good is going on over
there yeah that's exactly right 500 000
people and being able to handle that
amount of traffic
as a new company is is not easy so we
were really pleased with it
yeah so as this ecosystem kind of
kind of comes together are there other
pieces that you think
uh we need to be thinking about that
maybe we're not thinking about
well the the thing that we're not
thinking about i think
is just how you know payment processors
etc
exactly is how truly unstable the entire
online ecosystem is
right uh you mentioned payment
processors
uh there's there's sort of you know uh
the domain registration services that's
that's a big question
uh there are sort of you know cdn
services
that's a big question mark that i have
you know if you get
really far down the line and the tech
companies feel extraordinarily powerful
do you get to a point where if you type
in a website on a mobile browser
the browser won't actually resolve like
that sort of
hallmark of a free and open internet is
that if you type in a website you go to
that website
do the browsers themselves start
becoming agents of censorship
so what's crazy about the internet i
mean is that there are probably you know
40 or 50 really critical layers that
make it work from
sort of payments processing front-end
services all the way down to the
the back-end stuff that 99 of people
don't see or care about
um but at each level there are only a
few companies that actually control
things
right and so it's not inconceivable
that you have an internet where people
can't have access to it if they're not
sufficiently left-wing that's sort of a
big concern that i have
and i and i think that there are a lot
of good folks you know
a lot of good firms that are working on
ensuring there are alternatives that are
truly committed to free speech
so i'm you know i'm somewhat optimistic
that some of these alternatives are
coming online but i do in some way see
this as like a race
against the future because the left is
as you know is not becoming less crazy
it's actually becoming more crazy
and uh you know once they control the
information they really control the way
all of us think and that's pretty much
it
yeah is that part of the problem right
there that there's just sort of an
asymmetry
of who likes to use power i've been
talking about that a lot on the show
just that
we don't really want to use power even
in this conversation it's like ah
you know competition government it's
like we're sort of okay with competing
ideas being out there
where when they have the power we know
what they do
yeah that's that's exactly right you
know people always ask me the difference
between left and right is it small
government big government social
conservative
progressive what what have you and i
always say look the big difference
between the left and right
is the left loves to use power and the
right is terrified of using power
and uh you know my my friend richard
hanania who's is a really interesting
thinker on this he says the left
loves to use power because they actually
care about politics more
like you know you look at polling and
the right just doesn't care as much
about politics as the left does
i think unfortunately we're in an
environment where we have to get over it
because
if we're not willing to use power to
push back against the left i think that
power is going to come for us
it's going to come for our livelihood
it's going to come for our families it's
going to come eventually and already
started
coming for our very ability to speak and
to think for ourselves
and so i agree the left has a basic
instinctive advantage because they love
to use power
but we're just going to have to get over
it or we're going to find ourselves
without you know really
a real republic anymore yeah do you see
any sort of version of of any of this
ecosystem where there has to be some
regulations
around speech this is where the
gatekeeping conversation always comes in
you know are you gonna
let antifa coordinate on there on one
side versus
neo-nazis on another side or or
something like that
you know obviously there's some there's
some regulation in every sphere and i
tend to think that you know look we've
had a first amendment in our country for
245 years and it's worked
pretty well and the basic outline of the
first amendment
is that you're allowed to speak your
mind you're allowed to say the things
that you want to say
so long as you effectively don't incite
violence against other people right
there are very
narrow limits on what you're allowed to
say but there are some limits
and i think that's fine and i think that
should be the hallmark to how we think
about
the regulation of speech is
you know we we should be open to hearing
and debate
um so long as it doesn't run afoul of
the basic principles of the first
amendment
now now importantly like this doesn't
you know i think a lot of folks on the
left like to retreat and say well
you know are you not allowed to sort of
regulate a school curriculum for example
if you don't want to teach
four-year-olds
or eight-year-olds that they should hate
america and then america is a
fundamentally white supremacist country
uh is that like a violation of the first
amendment i think no no of course it
isn't right we've long
understood um that you know the way we
treat kids is different from the way we
treat adults and the purpose of our
schools
is to form people form young minds for
future leadership and
future citizenship uh so i think the
first amendment doesn't apply everywhere
right it applies to a 19 year old much
differently than it applies
to a three-year-old but i think that
should be our guiding principle
yeah that's actually exactly where i
want it to go next uh
all this critical race theory stuff and
that it's being pushed back against in
certain states
what's going on in ohio with this is
that one of the states that they're
making any headway with getting some of
this stuff out of the schools
yeah it really does feel like we're
making a lot of headway in ohio as a
matter of fact i mean we're
you know starting to see even you know i
live in southwestern ohio biggest city
here is cincinnati
and i'm starting to see stuff in some of
the suburban cincinnati school districts
where parents are starting to push back
against this stuff
you see them starting to mobilize to
take over some local school boards you
have
you know stay-at-home moms who never
really cared about politics who are
thinking about running for local school
board
and you also have some curriculum stuff
happening some of the state
organizations are really pushing back
against some of the curricula that's
coming unfortunately from our
universities and from our some
some of our state leaders saying look
you shouldn't be teaching kids to hate
themselves or hate their own country
you know one of the most heartbreaking
stories i've heard in the last few weeks
was from a dad who pulled his fifth
grader out of school in a suburban
cincinnati school district
and you know we often talk about this
stuff in two abstract terms right like
critical race theory is itself an
abstract term
but this guy pulled his daughter out of
school because she was coming home
really sad every day being taught that
she was effectively a bad person for
having white skin
and you think about the struggles we've
had in this country and what we've been
fighting for
and and i think progressing towards it's
like
aren't we supposed to think about people
based not on their skin color aren't we
supposed to be teaching our kids to look
deeper than skin color and how they
judge and evaluate people
and this just feels like a really
radical step backwards in the wrong
direction
and it's actually making our kids
unhappy that's what that's what really
bothers me about this
yeah so you're old school you think that
that mlk guy was pretty decent huh
you know i think the idea that we judge
people by the content of their character
is a pretty good principle to live by
uh and it's unfortunate that the left
seems unwilling to even follow it these
days
yeah so what other what other other
uh policies or platforms that you're
that you're running on that are unique
to ohio right now
you know the the big thing we're focused
on is the tech
issue the immigration issue um you know
people think i i think people understand
the immigration question
as fundamentally about law and order and
it is that right you don't have a real
country unless you have a southern
border with enforced
uh enforced limits but in ohio one of
the things the southern border means to
us
is the addiction epidemic gets much much
worse when you don't control what's
going on at the southern border so for
example
a few weeks ago biden administration
reported that you've seen fentanyl
seizures go up
four times over the same period last
year when i think trump to his credit
had a lot of control over the southern
border
that's what kills people in our
communities right so eventually that
fentanyl is going to start making it to
southwestern ohio communities it's going
to be more dead bodies from the
addiction epidemic
and people just you know i always hate
when the immigration issue is framed as
about xenophobia or racism
like you've got a grandma who's taking
care of a grandbaby
because her own daughter died of a
heroin overdose she doesn't care about
the southern border because she doesn't
like brown people she cares about the
southern border
because she doesn't want her grandson to
die of the same poison
that killed her daughter like this is
just common sense so the border's a big
thing for us obviously the big tech
issue is a big thing for us
and the thing we haven't talked about is
you know i'm a big believer that unless
you have an industrial base a
manufacturing base you don't have a real
country
right if you can't make pharmaceuticals
if you can't make surgical masks for
your doctors
if you can't make like basic computer
hardware that's necessary to operate
your defense industry
then you're fundamentally at the mercy
of another country like we're getting to
the point
where six years from now we could find
ourselves in a situation where we have
the same
missiles as china does but china's
missiles work
because they have computer chips in them
and our missiles don't because
the chinese control the computer chip
industry in the entire world
like this is really crazy and this is
unfortunately something that
leadership in both parties has been
complicit in so we're going to talk a
lot about manufacturing and the
manufacturing economy in our campaign
too
where do you think that stuff really
comes from like is it just that sort of
because of the success of america for
200
almost 50 years and and capitalism and
the extraordinary wealth and everything
else
that we just sort of got sold off piece
by piece and it's like
it was sort of nobody's fault and
everybody's fault at the exact same time
like there's just sort of nobody left
to to fix everything yeah i think that's
exactly right i think two big things
happened is
one we we felt that we could trade our
manufacturing economy
for a lot of cheap consumer goods right
to put it as dismissively as possible we
thought well
you know maybe we'll lose millions of
manufacturing jobs but we'll gain a lot
of cheap plastic garbage from china i
think that was a trade
that we should not have made in
hindsight but i think to your point more
importantly we forgot i think one of the
core historical lessons
of the american nation state which is
that it was built by an american
capitalist system
right our government you know was not
overbearing
but it made sure that core american
industries could prosper and flourish in
this country and importantly
the japanese and the chinese learned
from the american model in building
their own industrial economy it's it's
really a model that's worked
the world over and we sort of just
forgot and ignored it we sort of decided
that
you know we didn't really need to have
certain industries you know the law of
competitive advantage it was fine if
chinese made this thing and the
americans made this thing and that can't
you know the canadians made that thing
um but it turns out that like
maybe the canadians are a little bit
more reliable than the chinese for like
complex cultural and national security
reasons
and certainly maybe minnesota is much
more reliable than canada
or the chinese for some of these core
needs and so i think we just stopped
seeing the economy
as a thing that was you know sensitive
to
you know to to to human control we
thought that it would just work
by itself but of course all of our
regulations all of our tax policy all of
our laws
were affecting that market in ways we
were just kind of ignoring
do you think it's also that we kind of
took our eye off the ball with four
years of screaming that trump was a
russian
plant while china was actually doing a
lot of the stuff that was going to get
us here
yeah that's definitely right i mean we
definitely learned um
over the last four years that you know
the media especially can be easily
distracted it's like you know look a
squirrel right look russia look vladimir
putin
and we have all these really serious
problems look racism right i mean you
couldn't even talk about the origins of
the chinese
you know coronavirus for a long time
until
it became almost idiotic not to because
that was considered racist to ask the
origin
so i think unfortunately we have a
leadership class in this country you see
it in the businesses you see it in the
media you certainly see it in the
government
that is just completely unwilling to
talk about real problems
and uses these distractions so that we
you know basically don't notice the fact
that they're all failing us
so what do we do about the mainstream
media do we just let it do we let it die
at this point
almost every day on the show i have to
do some nonsensical story about what cnn
butchered or what
washington post lied about and then i
always posed the question to my audience
i'm like do i should i just start
ignoring this stuff because
we know their numbers are you know
bottoming out
or do we have to keep calling attention
to it because they still are
brainwashing x amount of people
i think it's a little bit of both i
think that we have to try to extract
ourselves from reliance on the
mainstream media as much as possible
but i also think you know it is
important to recognize that like your
show
probably has way more viewers than any
cnn show on any given day right
uh so i've got i've got one guy in this
room with me that's it
that's it am i my dog's under the table
that's right
so we are actually benefiting in some
ways from the rise of alternative media
sources
i mean i i think actually where you know
where i worry about this is sort of the
fusion of government and media and big
business right like the washington post
you should understand is effectively the
mouthpiece of jeff bezos
you know a lot of our biggest newspapers
and magazines are effectively controlled
um by business and in some ways
influenced by governmental interests
that sort of unholy alliance is what i
really worry about
is like okay so so jeff bezos owns the
washington post
he just effectively lobbied the us
congress
to cancel a grant given to one of his
business competitors this just happened
the last couple of days
for a space company blue origin where
now they've canceled the contract they
may re-award the contract to him
and you sort of start to wonder like
isn't this a really icky system
where you have media cooperating with
government cooperating with business to
control the flow of information
and control which decisions get made i
actually think you can probably break
the circuit
uh in in interesting ways and we should
try to do that because
yes the media is weaker but it's still
incredibly powerful
yeah so is that just through competition
then i mean is the breaking of the
circuit that we're going to build all
this stuff and then people were
there they'll have an off ramp yeah i
think it's a little bit through
competition i mean i've heard proposals
that suggest that like part of the
reason
the media is a little bit less crazy in
europe for example
is that they have more of a historical
first amendment whereas in america you
have this weird trumped-up first
amendment
where the media can effectively lie
about people without any real
consequences
and so maybe we need to sort of go back
to an era where
there's a little bit more consequence if
the media just tells an outright lie
about somebody like
you know if i'm a private citizen i tell
a lie about you
that causes you to lose your business
you can sue me for defamation it's
basically impossible to sue the media
for defamation these days
so there maybe are policy changes to be
made there too
um you know i'm not you know
i wouldn't sort of fully go down that
road just yet because i do think the
alternative media is actually rising in
a way that gives me some optimism
yeah you know to your point a couple
weeks ago someone in the new york times
once again basically called me
a white supremacist and i spoke to a
lawyer just for a second
you know i've been through this just
like you i've been through this a
million times
and and she's a great first amendment
lawyer and she was basically like look
you could dump a ton of money into this
but these laws are so tight that most
likely they have more money than you and
this isn't going to go anywhere and it's
just going to be a headache and
you know what somehow we just we all
survived being called white supremacists
somehow
yeah that's exactly right i've you know
had similar conversations i've been
called a white supremacist by the
washington post
and it is really crazy how it's
impossible for people
um to to face any consequences for this
stuff right it's kind of this crazy wild
wild west
where there's just no real law i mean
you remember the covington catholic kid
who was effectively slandered by every
mainstream journalist all over the world
um that kid fortunately as i understand
has gotten some
settlement but even that kid my
understanding is
is like it was not totally clear that
this 17 year old boy would have any
recourse
even though the entire mainstream press
came against him that's pretty
depressing stuff
yeah not only the mainstream press but
half of the
democrats in congress were saying how
this is proof that america's white
supremacist nation and it turns out that
it was all nonsense exactly including
our now sitting vice president
yeah speaking of our sitting vice
president
let's talk about the president for a
second um i've been saying for a while
that the scandal is the non-scandal
around this guy something is not right
with him it seems very obvious
everyone online is talking about it yet
no one in corporate press is talking
about it
like i don't know what what do you think
you know i i don't know i mean if
if you've ever known somebody with
dementia
one of the things you always notice is
that
they'll have this quick moment where
they forget where they are they almost
get like a sense of terror across their
face
and then they recover this is sort of
you know earlier onset dimension this is
not when people are really advanced
and there are sometimes like biden
reacts in a way where i almost think he
has
that look that sort of look where he
forgot where he was a second
remembered it very quickly but you watch
the guy on the world stage
you watch him in some of these meetings
it's just very clear
that so he's he's lost something he's
missed a step i don't know if that's
like
you know he's just older and he's aged
less gracefully than other people
or if he actually has a serious problem
but i find it bizarre
that people never talk about this i mean
you probably remember a couple of years
ago
like it was a serious mainstream story
to ask whether donald trump had like
dementia or alzheimer's
because he like you know mangled a
sentence in a speech or something like
that
or he got like you know he said the same
thing a few times in some remarks
he drank water like this remember and
it's like the guy has alzheimer's and
it's like you know
if you've ever met trump like he does
not come across as a guy who doesn't
know where he is
and biden is just so much worse on this
and yet the press is totally
uninterested in it i find it pretty
bizarre
the other side of this that is weird is
that it makes you wonder like who
actually has control right is that the
white house chief of staff is it the
vice president
is it some other staffer but like who's
making the decisions there like
i'd love to actually see just a good
documentary or piece of reporting about
what's actually or who is actually in
control in the white house
that that's exactly what i asked trump
about two weeks ago who do you think is
in charge
he actually didn't have a great answer
but all the time now we see biden get
out there
he fumbles through something and then he
says oh i'm gonna get in trouble
it's like with who that's right
that's right with like he's telling to
quote joe biden come on man like with
who are you going to get in trouble
but we just we just don't know so you
think kamala has taken over at some
point
you know i always assumed um you know
i've become more conspiracy minded
uh just because the it seems like our
elites
really are uh sometimes malicious and my
assumption is that you know
kamala will eventually take over maybe
it's in 2024
as the candidate maybe it's even earlier
than that i mean if if joe biden resigns
in the next two years
there is nothing that you will be able
to do convince me this was not a massive
conspiracy to install
a very unpopular person but like you
know i'll save the speculation until
later
my sense is that like the corporate wing
of the democrat
party recognizes like kamala's their gal
but also even the voters of the democrat
party don't like her
and so there's some sort of weird
bargain going on where she's eventually
going to assume the mantle
without real democratic control over the
process
and you know of course the country's
going to be that worse off for it but
hopefully
you know on our side we can stop that
from happening right so to get us to
back where we started to finish this
thing up so for the
average democrat that that gets all
everything you've heard you've said here
that they get it
but they're just afraid afraid of being
called a republican
afraid of being called a conservative
afraid of being called a trump supporter
you know all the stuff that it sounds
like you got over at some point i got
over at some point but
i get that those are those are legit
fears
what's your best pitch sort of as a
candidate but also as kind of like a
thought leader
in this thing to be like yeah we're not
all bad over here
you know my my best pitch is is first of
all
the people who are complaining about the
country voting for republicans voting
for trump
they actually do care about the future
they just want their kids to live in a
good country
and that's what animates them but i
think a lot of people on the left are
never going to really
hear that or appreciate that or
understand that um
but i i i think that the pitch that i
make to our own side
is that we have to be courageous and we
have to speak up right obviously there
are exceptions there are people
who are going to get fired if they say
the wrong thing at work that's actually
unfortunately
a complaint that i hear pretty
frequently when i'm out on the campaign
trail
but we just have to actually speak up
about this stuff right like
i was called a white supremacist in the
pages of the washington post
i almost lost a couple of business
contacts it was a very bad two days for
me
but then the dust cleared i didn't
apologize i didn't back down
and things were fine and i think so
often what we need to do and what we
need in this moment
is courage and friendship we need our
friends to be courageous as well
they need we need to know they're
supporting us but we just need to like
actually stand up to the mob because i
think every time somebody stands up to
the mob
and the mob backs down our side becomes
a little bit more powerful
that is a closing statement jd vance who
is good finally talking to you i'm sure
our paths will
cross again dave thanks for having me
and for folks who are interested in
helping the campaign jdvance.com please
go to our website
i would love to have your support now i
know you're a real
politician we'll link to it down below
too
all right thanks man if you're looking
for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics instead of
non-stop yelling check out our politics
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics watch
our full episode playlist all right over
here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell